[Musica]
ciao Toronto Toronto come state ragazzi
Cohen rispetto iniziale vedete come state
ragazzi cascada non ho capito niente come
state ragazzi non sentido iniziamo
bene la domanda di oggi è la richiesta
che il vostro GM sia alternativo cos'è l'
estere  serata alternativa
Mikasa ho solo 12 minuti per presentare il
mio piatto minuti para contar ella me
Astoria non so se è sufficiente
in salsa è sufficiente tempo ho avuto 30
anni di esperienza in 12 minuti nella
diluizione non importa se  possiamo uomo
su fantasia [ __ ] amo significa che
mi vedrai di nuovo qui bene caro comitato
con scritto Cora ok vorrei che
ci facessimo Vorrei che mi guardassi dove
posso dove spolverarli senza
considerare questa parte del mio corpo fa
questo  ma questo è soloq con il
barista giusto sembro un direttore
di banca poi guarda questa parte dove il
quiz la parte che è così cosa vedi
perché li ho fatti perché nel mio paese
Camerun neo pagano in Camerun quando
mi vedono  come questo  non importa
come sono vestito
non è divertente nel tono della cospirazione importa
la cosa che sono rapinatore a mano armata sono
ancora persone ok quindi niente rappy Natori
è divertente vero ma prima
ci sono le cose divertenti è che
non posso entrare in alcuni uffici  così anche
io sto bene vestito la mia parte presa per
reindirizzare una nuova funzione yo Casino post
entrada poi mi sposto dal Camerun
all'Europa quindim avviso pubblicato da Asano
Camerun la ropa a causa del mio aspetto la
gente mi chiede marijuana
per strada perk di  persona dell'assemblea amici
non dire oh de la marihuana
poi sono andato in Cambogia il punto miss è stato
pubblicato in Cambogia come puoi vedere nella
foto
mettilo via un carrello Martina ero
nero sai stretto puoi vedere
qualsiasi cosa laggiù
indosso per ultimo  uh-oh il Rasta ero
grande, vedi Grande e mi chiamavano
Mr.  grande hola me lamo no mr.  grande
ok io sono grande ok ecco perché sono qui
oggi per condividere con te la mia storia
Susanoo queer cantar ci mancherà Oliveira
Riprenderò la mia storia che può
aiutarti qui
più grande o più giovane diverso il rock
Queen Amazonia Joanna ti sveglia  in tre
fondamenti di base video intro fundament
il preside poi il primo
primo è il brutto sogno riguardo che è
Sonia qual è il tuo sogno
koala yo qual è il nostro sogno Kalil Nostra
Sonia qual è il mio sogno economia Oh Sonia
lo sai sono nato da un  povera
famiglia sig.  Parris oh no no non su
conosci familiare multiplo Vera puoi
immaginare guardando questa foto
Gina la queer prevenire vai Ho iniziato a
camminare a dieci anni e ha detto che
Oliver è un DHE su di me per guadagnare soldi per
pagare alcune delle mie cose ma boudin  Yara l'
hanno venduto quindi vengo da un paese in
cui il sistema medico è sale
prevenire andare non incollare il modo sistema un
sanitario o il primo kifo non abbiamo percorso
puoi vedere il nostro tipo di percorso no no bi
most rod no mettere una squadra  su Gina niente acqua
qui premi sul muro e hai l'
acqua ginocchio destro aperto dì sii Sonya vieni
in re Perdue geometria
niente elettricità non dirlo Rita poi
all'università dovevo camminare per studiare
durante il giorno per andare a scuola durante
il giorno
e camminare e fare due o tre lavori
durante la notte per poter pagare le
mie bollette Universidad de Punto liberado
studia reader fino a Jordan Oliver sono una
doppia antenna non poi dall'età
di 20 21 sono diventato uno dei principali
sostegno della mia famiglia e mi chiedo quando  -
Nani quindi non sostenere nemmeno totalmente il tuo
preside de mi familia
è una storia molto triste proprio unistream Alta
Tristan dove oh beh potresti solo
pero ella me Astoria faceva molto caldo quindi
a Malta difficile e mi stavo lamentando
accusando a Cal Poly tutti e tre gli ordini
per  essendo il responsabile della mia vita le
responsabilità di residenza coloca Devin
la mia vita ma poi ho iniziato a pensare
analizzando le unità della situazione le spille
sono su Elysee Tatiana e ho capito
che molti giovani della mia età nella
stessa situazione capito arrivavano multi-persona
Adela mr  .  theta sotto la controversia minoica
dice che prima ci chiamassimo Lost
Generation, conosci Marty lagina al SUNY
Pesa, ma ho deciso che non ne
farò parte
ora è così entusiasta della parte automobilistica di Sarah
una richiesta oh che è il benvenuto mio  sogno
fatto la regina non può mancare un mio sogno
di aiutare altri giovani e più giovani
di me ad avere una vita migliore Guevara
novita pasto sei un personaggio irritabile
Giovanni comune mr.  una vida million ma
sai rovinare una giornata Sonia
Madiba Sonia Delhi risorse ecco
quanto costano al secondo elemento
elemento base della mia vita sono i miei pilastri
Acosta - la seconda parte del mamita me
più tre oggi Sonia hai sognato
ma  se non hai soldi
MonaVie oggi ti negheranno
continuiamo io sono conservatore quindi no
ovviamente io sotto il traghetto ha continuato la
signora
ma oggi per esempio non sono qui per
soldi amico è MP og non sono più veloce  di
quanto molti dei miei sogni mi abbiano portato qui per
condividere con te
questa storia scusami Sonya scusa cui io
sono uno dei pilastri di questo
progetto sono orgoglioso di essere così no no il + 3 d
questo progetto OS quindi no meglio andare
Leo così da signore in basso, allora conosci i miei
pilastri nel momento in
cui ti ho detto tre fondamentali senza le
risorse non stai andando da nessuna parte sì
alla musa su devi in una fonte costante lo stess
a parte un punto lei non ha visto quadrupla una s
ringa popolare che  sono donne forse l'
ultima ragione Adela all'alba e queste donne  o
questi pilastri non sono apparsi
contemporaneamente Sedona non sono personale mmm
mangiato un esto momento perduto perché oggi
condivido con te 40 anni di storie
che potrebbero essere come quattro giorni o quattro
persone odubel canto Cuarenta in Vita
divisione Quattro  persona la prima
è che mia madre non immaginava che mi avesse insegnato l'
onestà la nostra responsabilità sta nel
dolore sin yato responsabilità' sai
quando siamo giovani vogliamo fare
cose da matti uscire con i nostri amici
Cepeda cuando se mojo vaniville Mo Farah
cosy  per diffamazione un mushi pensa che tu conosci l'
elettroencefalogramma non era un problema con
mia madre mi stava dicendo
clotee puoi uscire con i tuoi amici
puoi divertirti come vuoi puoi
tornare così
ma domani alle 5 ho bisogno di acqua  in
questa casa per visitare mia madre Belka deva
katta va bene per il tuo Shira poi e RA
in zero Connie per me lei diversità
teamollie Cinque debit o Nara casa
sai perché te l'ho detto che dobbiamo camminare
chilometri per trovare l'acqua
Cepeda nascita dai la tua data al promemoria
Camila comunità per chilometro e /
Truvada del agua poi la seconda la mia
seconda seconda Villa seconda Oh blaster mia
sorella Miele
mi ha insegnato la lotta e la perseveranza lay
Mia in senado la Lata perché quando io
perché quando ho iniziato  per mettere in pratica i
miei sogni è stata l'unica a
sostenermi motivandomi pensando
che fossi matto io sostengo il nostro
leaper sony pin 7 oq di Macondo prevedi percorso quindi
sì oggi sono fantastico ero pazzo ma
oggi sono qui con te
prima freccia  Pat Summerall G è su un
convoglio veloce a causa di lei un graduale
io sono qui quindi non probabilmente e quindi il
terzo pilastro della mia vita il Valastro de
la mia vita è mia moglie Amy Amalia che l'
adattamento di Alan e i dati di Celestine Kamiya
Insignia Tola intendevano  permettimi di
schema perché quando ho dovuto trasferirmi dal
mio paese per spendere Oh signorina Oh Naruto
potrebbe dire che era una di quelle che
mi diceva Chloe che non dovresti cambiare quello che
hai fatto per più di 10 anni
solo perché tu w  formica di adattarmi qui
perché le persone mi dicevano Chloe che
devi cambiare e studiare
elettricità meccanica perché dà lavoro qui lei
era l'unica a dirmi chakra dimmi
al bambino in quella regina di storia dell'arte va bene dici che
facciamo causa al silicone DRA e all'ingegnere
meccanico un cotone  su Debbie Farlow
poi le ho dedicato il mio master
in economia sociale e solidale epopea
occidentale dedicado
me Lamia laurea Magistrale in una
sociologia io economia e poi la quarta
è mia figlia el cuarto Valastro Emilia
flessibilità e speranza significa molta
flessibilità Esperanza sai quando
hai un figlio quindi quando hai
persone più giovani dietro di te hai speranza
svelto augura loro il meglio cuando
Chisinau d bimini sono le persone fu
Johnny Lavoy
coloca vida no Esperanza quindi parliamo
di sogno parliamo di Phyllis
Sono sovraccarico Sonya Debbie  ultime tre
le terze azioni non agire
non sei niente azione in due modi in
Camerun quel momento in cui ho iniziato
a sognare il cambiamento  ing la mia società
ho iniziato azioni azione cosa l'educazione
dei bambini e lo sviluppo dei giovani
in questa immagine è una delle decisioni di
più di 10 progetti che abbiamo realizzato
lì sulla base dell'educazione Sto parlando
di più di 12.000 bambini che hanno
beneficiato di questo progetto  in
Camerun sono di più e milla bambini una specie di
Trottatore ha beneficiato di MEA proiettando un chana
quindi non è lo stesso Pradeep tu ho deciso o di
continuare ha detto che ho continuato a
lamentarmi elemento esercito all'immagine
aggiungi JIRA se avessi continuato a
lamentarmi non avrò essere  qui
fammi intervenire su scusa veloce inviato
energia quindi dal Camerun ho iniziato a
lavorare dopo anni arriveranno è
un dito a la Isla de peau de Leon E e
poi il pianeta si muove puoi capire
questo Canada vedere più di una turbina cumbia Laputa
capira e lei ha detto Cloutier
devi venire in Spagna mmm solo io me
dijo que trata de espana e poi
seguo il mio cuore
una regina yo ciguatera Cora ma in Spagna
non ci siamo fermati abbiamo detto di no  w che sei
qui
dovremmo fermarci no perché questo è come
parte del mio DNA quindi è come fluire nel
mio sangue quello che sto facendo per la mia società
ma la regina spagnola de Medici il Rhema
per il supermercato sì no quindi io
parte de mio DNA  noi donne Coronel poi
abbiamo creato un altro progetto o un'altra
organizzazione in Spagna che si
occupa anche dell'educazione dei giovani
ma ora puntando sull'orientamento del Camerun
e dell'intera Europa si può vedere
sull'alluvione che ci sono molti paesi ma
stiamo parlando di 50
paesi in cui stiamo lavorando stiamo parlando
di 500 giovani che hanno partecipato
al corso di formazione e si prendono le modifiche
quindi abbiamo DG quindi la media extra
jeonnam faranno DiGiovanni a partir -
cameron arrestato da mcconnell amaretto
canal tree Queenie pecore vedo che è su
un  pitch in crescendo persona Giovanni
convulsion questo progetto quindi per concludere
come noi per dare un'occhiata a questo e questo
guarda per un concerto dove fa il
Questor Alonso sai quando guardo  Tornando indietro di
molti anni più di 20 anni fa
ero qualcuno che si lamentava incolpando accusando le
persone ma oggi quando sono qui a condividere
con te mi sento felice perché sto
trasmettendo qualcosa non solo alla mia
società ma vado oltre il confine
oltre  il confine del mio paese chiunque
in questa stanza quindi di' matita sono stato
taggato nifa cuando me deplorevole rotante
resta [ __ ] un piatto quindi no quiso nessun convoglio
è così no Felicia ma que el progreso no
knee e quell'assalto a Tony
elementi limitati un ghepardo  la Lamia il popolare
zio turco Otto Questacon fini
chiunque di questa stanza dovrebbe pensare a
questa volta è denaro se ci incontriamo l'anno prossimo
o dopo due anni sarei felice per
tanti giovani che sono seduti in
questa stanza sarò felice di essere lì
e ascoltando la loro storia ascoltano
che sono stati motivati da ciò che hanno impar
to da questo evento sarò felice di saper
che sono diventati un'alternativa a Toron
o a quindi una persona que qui dentr
volley okay satya ke te  mpo
equivalent NRO
/ qu e break a Trudeau eonni otra nano
una persona cos Costa del mio discorso
Passat are a spirit Co Nepos sempre ra
da questa vento arrest rel alternate'
IVA / Toronto
so tre importanti ting dream pillars
e action malt importanti a Sonia plus
proprietario dell'albero arz tutto dovrebbe essere in
questo triangolo in modo tale che tu possa
stare dentro perché se sei fuori dal
triangolo sei perso da Toby's per
sviluppare un interno sterile el triángulo
sí a for adultery angola quindi sai
richiedere un for  adulterio su globale vedi il
pappagallo si grazie Mille grazie Mille
tu